- The first time I saw
Sadu, it was in a small shop
in the old town of Dubai.
I just fell in love with these patterns.
So I thought that it
would look really stunning
to take something so
Bedouin, and so heritage,
and make it so modern.
(gentle techno music)
My name is Katya Kovtunovich.
I live in Dubai, and
I'm a fashion designer.
And working with Sadu is my big passion.
Sadu was originally made by
Bedouin women in the desert.
They would weave them
for weeks and months,
but there are still amazing
artisans that make it by hand.
So it's a very, very complicated art,
and it's actually an art
that is disappearing.
When you touch this
fabric, you really feel
it's so different; it has a soul.
(quiet music)
I always just set myself
free and I do whatever
I want with fabric.
A lot of inspiration comes from traveling,
from living in different
countries, living in London,
observing different cultures,
and finding something
that exists in one
culture and translating it
into another culture.
The most interesting
thing about this fabric
is the stripes, that you
can take the same color,
the same fabric, and
reconstruct it in so many ways.
One stripe can go horizontally,
one stripe can go vertically,
one stripe can go across,
so you create a very different
movement on the body.
Working and creating in Dubai,
it's a truly unique experience.
Everything is coming up,
the pop art, the music,
so it's just pure, calm inspiration.
Nothing stops me.
I can go and buy fabrics at 1:00 a.m.,
I can finish my photo shoot at 3:00 a.m.
You feel like anything you
desire, you can accomplish.
Dubai is the city where the
word impossible doesn't exist.
I think my project with
Sadu is something global.
I love to see women wearing
it, and being complimented,
and feeling special.
And I only see a very
beautiful, interesting future.